florian philippot pour vous il faut tout
rires bah oui parce que le soleil a pas
deux il n'y a pas de lien entre ça qu'il
faut sortir de la tête des gens n'y a
pas de lien entre les restrictions de
liberté les couvre-feux les confinements
les fermetures et la dynamique d'une
épidémie c'est pas ça une politique de
santé publique
petit guide santé publique c'est prendre
sereinement les choses sur la prévention
le système immunitaire le traitement
quel énorme tabou vraiment à mon avis
derrière ya des problèmes de corruption
d'ailleurs les traitements qui sont pas
autorisés à 10 ans à basse terre que
vous avez des traitements faut la
chloroquine parler oui l'euro qui
n'hésiteront micinn l'ivermectine ans
avec 40 étudiants un article de capital
là qui est sorti un mois c'est pas la
gazette des patriotes qui disent quoi
qu'il dise que c'est 40 études dont 20
en double aveugle qui montre que c'est
extrêmement efficace et des pays qui
l'utilisent le portugal en ce moment
l'utilisent alors on va s'arrêter deux
secondes là dessus parce qu'on a on a le
besoin
un exemple pour expliquer relance est
peut-être le débat il ya le 10 mars le
texas qui est le deuxième état le plus
peuplé des états unis en mai le
mississippi c'est pareil tout ouvre-toi
100% mais nouveau tout et on enlève le
masque obligatoire
les gens qui veulent le mettre il le met
ne sait pas où il est en principe hayden
dit ça va être
mais c'est une erreur fatale je le cite
c'est une décision néandertalienne c'est
à dire un peu arriérés bon je souhaite
une station ultra courant
je connais un mois et demi plus tard les
contaminations sont en baisse c'était à
la est bien mieux en mieux positionné
parmi les états américains donc en fait
il fallait ils ont même fait trente huit
mille spectateurs ou pour le baseball
dans un stade là le 6 avril bah il faut
arrêter ce délire et sinon on va tous
tués dans le pays selon m on va tuer non
seulement les restaurateurs les
commerces mais la vie la vie
démocratique les libertés la psychologie
la morale l'économie enfin la boralde et
le moral des gens là dessus dans un
instant c'était pas de manigold à vous
répondre je sais que stéphane déjà en un
mot je sais qu'on n'est pas d'accord
avec florian philippot non je suis pas
d'accord avec les incantations flanc
filipe luis mizon de bougies un peu
comme certains politiques et il fait de
l'incantation la vraie vie ne sais pas
si on est marseillais
je veux dire je suis je vais vous
répondre restons ouverts vous est
familier on va y arriver
bachand je ne vous inquiétez pas donc
vous vous êtes dans l'ain quant à jo
mais vous faites de la politique
moi je suis un chef d'entreprise vous
vous n'avez jamais travaillé de votre
vie donc forcer le jeu semblait si vous
voulez entendre de ma part oui photo
ouvre demain
factuellement je vous répondrais oui
mais la vérité c'est quand on est chef
d'entreprise
nos agriculteurs et belle faut qu'ils
reproduisent un peu pour alimenter
l'ensemble des restaurants faut qu'on
fasse venir nos salariés pourquoi leur
forme
parce que nous on fait pas juste de
l'incantation ont fait de la cuisine
alors quoi on est des artisans monsieur
finir de le dire demain à souffrir c'est
prévu ça y est c'est qu'elle attendait
tout ce que vous faites c'est de la
politique des croyants phase arrêtée sur
la politique de la montre cassé c'est à
dire que non casse et même unique à
celle de leurs deux fois par jour juste
c'est lamentable de six à dix longueurs
et bresson